thank you mr speaker i'd like to talk  about how children feel about mask  while they're watching television seen  super bowl games where adults are filled  filling stadiums why is she out of  breath  and enjoying themselves while they see  concerts happen they see people go to  work they see adults going many places  all over this country without masks  you're forced to wear masks every single  day at school and it's wrong actually  it's child abuse abuse i know that  sounds like strong words but it really  is sounds crazy children  are not at risk of covid19  matter of fact children are at the  lowest risk but do you know what's right  having their faces covered all day long  at school not being able to see each  other's faces not being able to see  their teachers faces not being able to  learn crazy